bonjour et merci d'être avec nous sur rt
france vous êtes contre l'indépendance
de la nouvelle calédonie alors on
imagine vous êtes satisfaite par ces
premiers résultats qui font toutefois
état d'un écart visiblement serré entre
loyalistes et indépendantistes le oui
est en progression toutefois par rapport
au référendum de 2018
en fait le grand événement d'abord de ce
résultat c'est le fait d'avoir une forte
participation c'est à dire que les
abstentionnistes ont été votées et
effectivement il ya eu un petit
resserrement en nombre de en pourcentage
du résultat mais en fait ce sont tout
simplement les indépendantistes qui ont
été qui avait été plus abstentionnistes
lors du premier scrutin et qui le sont
moins lors de ce deuxième scrutin
mais il n'y a pas eu de basculement en
fait un de voix du nord vers le oui et
donc qu'on a avec un taux de
participation extrêmement important des
calédoniens qui se sont très largement
exprimée pour le maintien de la
calédonie dans la france et c'est la
deuxième fois qu'ils le font aussi
clairement une participation record plus
de 85% cc points de plus qu'en 2018
qu'est ce que tu as qu est ce que cela
révèle selon vous ça révèle qu'il ya un
très grand intérêt pour ce scrutin c'est
à dire qu'on voit bien une nouvelle
calédonie l'enjeu de savoir si on veut
rester français il pas et les risques
d'une indépendance éventuel donc il ya
eu une mobilisation majeure lors de ce
scrutin des deux des deux camps le camp
de ce qu'ils veulent comme moi que la
nouvelle qu'elle me reste dans la france
qui ont voté pour
pour continuer à être protégé par la
république française
et puis ceux qui ont voté pour
l'indépendance qui l'ont fait sans doute
pour des raisons identitaires de
reconnaissance de lost et kanak alors
vous présidez la province sud de
nouvelle-calédonie la plus peuplée au
résident et européens
lors du premier référendum les trois
quarts des suffrages s'était porté sur
le non à la différence du nord à
majorité kanak où le oui l'avait
largement emporté on attend évidemment
les résultats définitifs de cette
deuxième consultation mais le même
scénario semble se répéter quel destin
commun aujourd'hui pour les calédoniens
comment réunir toutes les communautés
évitez les clivages d'abord ce qui est
absolument essentiel c'est que on arrive
à dialoguer les uns avec les autres
c'est à dire que malheureusement ça fait
donc deux référendum que nous faisons
aujourd'hui on voit bien que les
résultats sont confirmés les calédoniens
avec une un taux de participation
majeure ont décidé de rester français
je vois pas l'intérêt qu'on a il ya un
troisième référendum à une troisième
fois cette même question
on sait très bien que maintenant que se
sont exprimés deux fois alex wiens
confirmeront ce vote donc l'idée c'est
maintenant de se retrouver autour de la
table pour construire une solution qui
réponde aux attentes des uns et des
autres qui répondent évidemment à la
majorité qui souhaitent maintenir cette
protection de la république française et
qui répondent aussi aux attentes des
indépendantistes en matière de
reconnaissance identitaire et pour ça
c'est vrai qu'on voit bien et vous
l'avez l'avait dit il ya des différences
majeures entre la province sud et les
provinces nouri puisqu'on a des
résultats qui sont quasiment inversée en
faveur ou contre l'indépendance et donc
l'idée pour nous c'est de valoriser ces
différences et de considérer de prendre
en compte les différences de mode de vie
qu'il ya entre les habitants de la
province sud et cela pour instaurer de
la voir avec le dialogue est possible
aujourd'hui avec les indépendantes et
cette filière des échanges entre
loyalistes et indépendantistes en
nouvelle calédonie oui bien sûr les
échanges sont aussi alors c'est vrai que
malheureusement ces scrutins successifs
limite c'est possible et de dialogue
puisque en fait chacun est enfermé dans
des postures électorale avec avec des
référendums successifs avec au milieu de
ce référendum des élections locales
et c'est vrai que du coup ça ça empêche
les uns et les autres d'entrer dans un
dialogue sincère et constructif là on
arrive dans une période finalement
plutôt celle où pendant les deux
prochaines années
on n'a pas de scrutin local on a la
possibilité d'avoir cette discussion
pour essayer d'offrir enfin aux
calédoniens des perspectives un peu
supérieur aux deux ans de visibilité
pour leur offre depuis quelques années
et enfin de leur offrir un avenir commun
dans mo pour quelles raisons selon vous
le territoire doit rester français
pour énormément de raison c'est vrai on
est au milieu du pacifique et la france
nous apporte une protection importante
est notamment on a chez nos voisins une
une forme de colonisation économique de
la chine vous voici un certain nombre de
nos voisins insulaires la france nous
protège de cette colonisation économique
la france nous apporte également de la
de l'impartialité en matière de justice
en matière de sécurité la france nous
apporte finalement ses forces dans tout
en nous laissant énormément de liberté
pour nous organiser comme souhaité merci
beaucoup d'avoir pris le temps de
répondre à nos questions sur arte france
sonia backès présidente de l'assemblée
de la province sud de nouvelle-calédonie